comment confond avec quelqu'un vous dit
pas ce qu'on a déjà des vues confondu
avec un autre acteur quelqu'un de connu
une fois c'était très flatteur mais
c'était ce n'est pas en france mais n'en
passe pas souvent mais qui une fois ça
me fait une très bonne parce que je ne
trouve pas mais une fois on m'a pris
pour russell crowe à messi abbas avait
là quelque chose oui bah j'espère moi
j'ai trouvé ça très flatteur en fait
penser je ne sais pas ça philippe
lellouche pour quelqu'un d'autre
l'aurait non j'avais castaldi a un peu à
christophe lambert
ah oui vous jugent pas nicolas hulot
mais en ce moment des mains hier matin
il hier matin quelqu'un m'a dit pas de
chance d'avoir été éliminé de ma singer
non mais c'est vrai qu'un petit terrain
ouais ouais on vous prend pour qui
on m'a déjà pris pour clara morgane
c'est vrai dans la rue à écouter bas
[Rires]
elle est très belle dit jean-michel à
moi c'est pas le même délire c'est jean
luc lemoine il est beau gosse jean-luc a
mouse isabelle moret vous qu'on m'a
souvent confondu avec moi même c'est à
dire que des gens de zéro on dirait me
isabelle morini bosc
ah ben non elle est mieux dans laquelle
on attend les ventes du remicade et
lycées vous dire c'est là qu'est ce
qu'elle a le don de raconter
c'est fou ça donc savourer mots voilà ça
je bascule la antonio banderas quoi ces
métiers là et regardez bien ce qui est
mignon c'est que oreilles il n'a pas du
tout envie de se marrer quand il sortait
un petit îlot mercier valérie et
j'espère vous et dire à la personne
puisque c'est à l'aéroport et mondiale à
laon vous adore moi alors je dis assez
moi je me gausse mais je ne dis rien et
me convient fait la femme noire dans le
film
c'était pas du tout moi j'ai dit ah oui
oui on joue le jeu c'est très gênant
pour les gens c'est moi j'ai eu le même
problème avec qui ont beaucoup coûté
m